we have defined the conditional
expectation of a random variable given
another as an abstract object which is
itself a random variable let us now do
something analogous with the notion of a
conditional variance let us start with a
definition of the variance which is the
following
we look at the deviation of the random
variable from its mean square it and
take the average of that quantity if we
live in a conditional universe where we
are told the value of some other random
variable capital Y then inside that
conditional universe the variance
becomes the following it is defined the
same way well in the conditional
universe this is the expected value of X
so this quantity here is the deviation
of X from its expected value in that
conditional universe we square this
quantity we find the square deviation
and we look at the expected value of
that square deviation but because we
live in a conditional universe of course
this expectation has to be a conditional
one given the information that we have
available so this is nothing but the
ordinary variance but it's the variance
of the conditional distribution of the
random variable capital X this is an
equality between numbers if I tell you
the value of little Y the conditional
variance is defined by this particular
quantity which is a number now we
proceed in the same way as we proceeded
for the case where we defined the
conditional expectation as a random
variable namely we think of this
quantity as a function of little Y and
that function can be now used to define
a random variable and that random
variable which we denote this way this
is the random variable which takes this
specific value when capital Y happens to
be equal to little Y once we know the
value of capital Y then this quantity
takes a specific value but before we
know the value of capital why then this
quantity is not known it's random it's a
random variable let us look at an
example to make this more concrete
suppose that Y is a random variable we
draw the trend of variable and we're
told that conditioned on the value of
that random variable X is going to be
uniform on this particular interval from
zero to Y so if I tell you that Capital
y takes on a specific numerical value
then the random variable X is uniform on
the interval from zero to little Y a
random variable that uniform on an
interval of length little Y has a
variance that we know what it is it's Y
squared over 12 so this is an equality
between numbers for any specific value
of little Y this is the numerical value
of the conditional variance let us now
change this equality between numbers
into an abstract equality between random
variables the random variable variance
of X given Y is a random variable that
takes this value whenever Capital y is
little Y but that's the same as this
random variable this is a random
variable that takes this value whenever
capital y happens to be equal to little
Y so we have defined the abstract
concept of a conditional variance
similar to the case of conditional
expectations for conditional
expectations we had the law of iterated
expectations that tells us that the
expected value of the conditional
expectation is the unconditional
expectation is it true that the expected
value of the conditional variance is
going to be the same as the
unconditional variance and fortunately
know things are a little more
complicated the unconditional variance
is equal to the expected value of the
conditional variance but there is an
extra term that is the variance of the
conditional expectations the entries
here in red are all random variables
so the conditional variance has been
defined as a random variable so it has
an expectation of its own the
conditional expectation as we have
already discussed it's also a random
variable so it has a variance of its own
and by adding those terms we get the
total variance of the random variable X
so what we will do next will be first to
prove this equality and then give a
number of examples that are going to
give us some intuition about what these
terms mean and why this equality makes
sense